aquí tenemos una pizza entera y digamos
que quiero partirla en dos partes
iguales vamos a cortarla a la mitad para
tener dos partes iguales y digamos que
me comí una de estas piezas o uno de
estos pedazos me comí todo esto de aquí
que fracción de la pizza me he comido
bueno quedamos que tomamos una pizza
entera y la dividimos en dos partes
iguales dos partes iguales de las cuales
me comí una pieza esta pieza de acá por
lo que me comí un medio la mitad de la
pizza ahora imaginemos que en lugar de
partir esta pizza en dos partes iguales
ahora la quiero partir en cuatro partes
iguales así que vamos a poner aquí o
trapiche entera pero ahora en lugar de
dividirla por la mitad
voy a dividirla en cuartos en cuatro
partes iguales aquí la corto de esta
manera
luego la puedo cortar de esta de otra
manera ya tengo mis cuatro pedazos así
que tenemos cuatro partes iguales y
digamos que ahora me quiero comer la
misma cantidad de pizza que en el
ejemplo anterior cuántos pedazos me
tengo que comer y los invitó a que pausa
en el vídeo para que traten de hacer
esto por su cuenta bueno pues me comeré
este pedazo y este otro pedazo de aquí
abajo me he comido la misma cantidad de
la pizza este pedazo de acá pueden
imaginarse que lo partí a la mitad en
otras dos piezas iguales que son estas
de acá en la pizza que está dividido en
cuatro partes así que me comí dos
rebanadas de las cuatro que había
originalmente me comí dos cuartos de
pizza y aquí aunque estoy usando números
diferentes este un medio que se ve
diferente al dos cuartos o uno en el
numerador dos en el denominador y de
este lado tengo dos en el numerador y
cuatro en el denominador estas dos
fracciones representan exactamente la
misma cantidad ya que me comí la misma
cantidad de pizza el comerme dos cuartos
de pizza es lo mismo que el comerme la
mitad
de la pizza o un medio de pizza así que
decimos que estas dos cosas son
equivalentes fracciones equivalentes
ahora veamos otro ejemplo en lugar de
dividir la pizza en cuatro partes
iguales vamos a dividirla en ocho partes
iguales aquí tenemos de nuevo nuestra
pizza entera y ahora podemos cortarla
así aquí en medio
aquí horizontalmente como en el ejemplo
anterior y aquí en diagonal aquí y acá
para tener nuestros ocho partes iguales
son nuestros ocho pedazos iguales vamos
a tratar de hacerlo lo más parejo
posible aunque como es dibujo a mano
luego no queda tan parejo entonces
tenemos ocho pedazos iguales y digamos
que me quiero comer la misma cantidad de
pizza que en los ejemplos anteriores
cuantas rebanadas tengo que comer para
lograr esto pues no puedo comer todas
estas piezas todos estos pedazos cuántos
pedazos son pues me comí uno dos tres
cuatro cuatro partes y de nuevo esta
fracción cuatro octavos cuatro entre
ocho es equivalente a dos cuartos y
también es equivalente a un medio y
ustedes pueden ver aquí un patrón para
pasar de este ejemplo a este otro tengo
el doble de piezas en las que partía el
entero y también el doble de las piezas
que me comí así que como tenía el doble
de pedazos pues tuve que comer
de rebanadas que había comido en el
ejemplo original así que multiplique el
denominador por 2 y el numerador también
lo multiplique por 2 y como estoy
multiplicando el numerador y el
denominador por la misma cantidad
realmente no estoy cambiando la fracción
y lo mismo vemos de este otro lado
cuando pasamos de 4 rebanadas a 8
rebanadas corté cada rebanada original
en dos así que tengo el doble de
rebanadas por lo que multiplicó por 2 el
denominador y si quiero comer la misma
cantidad pues tengo que comer el doble
de rebanadas que la anterior así que
todas estas un medio dos cuartos y
cuatro octavos y bueno puedo seguir
dividirlo en dieciséis y comerme ocho
rebanadas todas éstas van a ser
fracciones equivalentes